so one of the things that does keep
coming up in my research
uh is that there seems to be often in
some of these oldest companies and
organizations
um a person who tells the stories and
connects the generation
to generation within companies and
organizations
in some places that's that's highly
cultivated like the temples in japan
but in some places it's very informal
and sometimes it's a you know it's a
parent of a founder
or um even you know in some cases like a
janitor who's
who's been there for decades and tells
the stories of
how certain things survived in the past
and sometimes they're the person that
you know remembers the last plague or
the last
war and can remind current management
what what they did during that time in
order to weather it or
if the management is let's say proposing
a new project
this person might remind them oh you
know what we tried that and it really
didn't work and maybe it could work now
with new tools in a new time
but here's why it didn't work then and
so many of these institutions kind of
have this
have this person and um i think one of
the places that i found that it's
interestingly um you know very
formalized is
in some of the cathedrals in europe like
salisbury cathedral which has
been around for over 800 years
and they have a person there whose title
is called the keeper of the fabric which
is kind of my favorite title
for these uh type of people they have
you know roles of keeping track of the
finances and
basic administrative tasks but they also
have this role of really kind of
bridging generational conversations
and in fact i think what's interesting
about the salisbury cathedral is that
the
oldest continuously operating clock is
the tower clock
that's in that cathedral and that keeper
of the fabrics their
job one of their jobs is to to help make
sure these things are maintained between
some of the wars and difficult financial
times
or technical failures that it has to
recover from
we might imagine how keepers of the
fabric could be cultivated in the
institutions that we have in the world
to help them last these keepers of the
fabric can
in some cases mean the difference
between life and death
an amazing counter example to the very
first one i started this talk with
are the sentinelese tribes of the
andaman islands
in the indian ocean and these tribes are
are small a few thousand people but they
have had these kind of keepers of the
fabric
to tell oral traditional stories over
as many as i think what we now know to
be about 60
000 years their island was heavily
affected by the 2004 tsunami
um off the coast of indonesia that wiped
out you know huge chunks of modern
culture and when the anthropologist
arrived at this
largely uh fishing uh kind of sustenance
village assuming that it was going to be
wiped out
in these islands they found them totally
intact and they asked them you know what
how did you
survive this tsunami and they said you
know this is a tribe that's that's been
on these islands for over 60 000 years
an african diaspora tribe for 60 000
years and they have a
a totally oral storytelling tradition
that's helped along by shamans and
chiefs and
and storytellers within their
communities that said when the
when the when the water recedes just
like it does in a normal wave cycle
that it's always going to come back and
eat at least an equal amount
and so when they saw the water receding
during the beginning
the antecedent to the last tsunami they
ran for the hills
whereas you saw people in modern-day
bangladesh and indonesia
standing on the beach with cell phones
filming the water going out
not thinking that it was going to have
this reciprocal effect so it was this
very old knowledge
these keepers of the fabric that helped
save life
save property save and save culture
over time and i think the question is
you know who
are the keepers of our fabric i think
you know private organizations and
religions interestingly
kind of have these um more than others
um i think you know a lot of our
cultural institutions like libraries
and museums are kind of hit and miss on
this
governments generally are pretty bad at
this but we can imagine that you know we
certainly want government data like
birth and death records
um government data from you know the
world health organization from this
pandemic to the next
we want that information to survive um i
think
the last example i'll give is is of a of
a good
example and a story of kind of a hero of
the keeper of the fabric
who was unappreciated in his time in
another city in japan
and it was a mayor it was a 10-term
mayor uh in this city
um who was dead long before the last big
tsunami
and he actually right he pulled together
government resources and funding
to build this you know actually fairly
ugly massive 51-foot sea wall
pretty high in a city that's pretty far
away from from the ocean much further
away than other ones were
and he was ridiculed and told that you
know that this was a waste of money and
that it didn't look good
and this this sea wall was closed just
in time to save the city
from the last uh from the last tsunami
well as cities all around it who had
only built
you know uh sea walls that were 30 feet
tall were wiped out in fact the sea
walls
basically helped keep the water in once
the once the water came over them and it
was because this mayor had a
had cultural memory from tell the
stories that were told to him
by his elders and he kept it relevant he
had enough power within government
and respect and length in government
to build something that nobody else
would ever have the kind of
cultural power and social power
and economic power to do so we can all
i think take these examples and
try and figure out what institutions we
want to last for a long time
what is the type of information that we
and who are we going to have within
these institutions and how are we going
to empower them
to be the keepers of the fabric to make
sure
that we survive the the kind of the
difficulties of the calamities that we
might live through
and more than that really thrive and
have an have a civilization
that can last in the next 10 000 years
hopefully better than we have
in the last 10 000 years